Now in the beginning of this unit I did a little magic trick
having to do with coloring in region in a map.
This problem is sometimes called map coloring.
and just to remind you, the idea there is that each of the region in the map
we're going to assign some color to it with the constraint that there can't be
the same color in two adjacent regions on the map.
because then it would kind of make it look like one big region.
We can actually think of this as a problem
on graphs. In particular, we're going to make each region on the map correspond to a node on the graph
and we're going to connect two nodes on the graph if they share a border and therefore can't
have the same color on the map.
"a" shares a border with "b" and "f"
"f" shares borders with "g", "b", and "a"
"b" shares borders with "a" and "f" that we haven't
already and "g" and "c"
"c" shares borders with "d" and "h"
"h" shares borders with "g" and "e"
and "d". "gcde"
"d" and "e" share a border
Did I get everything?
"h" doesn't connect to "b". "g" doesn't connect to "c" - yes it does.
"g" has borders with "f", "b", "c", and "h."
Given that transformation, the equivalent graph coloring problem is going to be
given a graph G and some number k, can we assign
each of the nodes of the graph, a color, specifically some number between 1-K so that
neighbors in the graph have different numbers assigned
to them. turns out this problem comes up a lot - not just in geography.
but also in computer science applications.
for example, in compilers, trying to figure out how to use the registers
of the computer to evaluate expressions
and it also comes up in social network problems. you can imagine saying
"ok i've got a group of people, here is their friend network, and what I'd like to do is group them into K different groups so that within each each group there is no pairwise friends"
so you can think of this as building mixer, like a party where you want to invite your friends but you want
them to interact with people they aren't already friends with